determine whether 394
is greater than or less than 397
then write the expression that shows
this using either well this symbol or
that symbol and this is actually the
less than symbol and we'll think a
little bit more about how to remember
that that is the less than symbol and
this is the greater than symbol
greater than so first of all let's just
look at the two numbers 394 and 397 so
let me write them down
394 and the other number is 397.
now they both have three hundreds so
their hundreds places equivalent they
both have 90 with that nine there but
this is 300 plus 90 plus four
plus four and this is 300 plus 90 plus 7
and we know that 4 is less than 7. if
you look on a number line 4 comes before
7 if you're counting to 7 you're going
to pass up 4. so 394 is less than
and the way that we write that we would
just write
is less than
and the way the way i remember that this
means less than
less
than
is that the smaller number is on the
side that has kind of a smaller side you
can imagine this side is much smaller
than this side over here we could also
write the other way we could write 397
is greater than 394
and once again the bigger number is the
side that this little thing is opening
onto or the side that has a i guess the
bigger side of this symbol right here
this point is the smaller side this out
here is the bigger side that's where you
put the larger number greater than less
than